i mean that's such a human
thing of that moment of genius of
figuring out the
intuition of of good essentially i mean
we thought that that is it maybe it's
not right we thought that about chess
right that exactly exactly that the
ability to see like
10 15 sometimes 20 steps ahead
was not a calculation that humans were
performing it was some kind of weird
intuition about
different patterns about board positions
about the relative positions exactly
somehow stitching stuff together and a
lot of it is just like intuition
but then you you have like alpha i guess
zero be the first one that did uh
the self-play it just came up with this
it's it was able to learn to self-play
mechanism this kind of intuition
exactly but just like you said it's so
fascinating to think
well they're in the space of totally new
ideas can that be done
in in developing theorems we know it can
be done by neural networks because we
did it with the neural networks in the
cranium those are the great
mathematicians of our
of humanity right and and i'm so glad
you brought up alpha zero because that's
the counter example
it turned out we were flattering
ourselves when we said
intuition is something different it's
only humans can do it it's not
information processing
if you if it used to be that way
that you know again it's very it's
really instructive i think to compare
the chess computer deep blue that beat
kasparov
with alpha zero that beat lisa doll at
the go
because for deep blue there was no
intuition
there was some pro humans had programmed
in some intuition
after humans had played a lot of games
they told the computer you know
count the pawn as one point the uh
bishop is three points
the rook is five points and so on you
add it all up and then you add some
extra points for past
pawns and subtract if the opponent has
it and
and blah blah blah blah and then
what what deep blue did was just search
just very brute force tried many many
moves ahead all these combinations and
the pruned research
and it could think much faster than
kasparov and it won
[Music]
and that i think inflated our egos in a
way it shouldn't have because people
started to say
yeah yeah it's just brute force search
but has no intuition yeah
alpha zero really
popped our bubble there yeah because
what alpha zero does yes it does also do
some of that research
but it also has this intuition module
which in geek speak is called the value
function
where it just looks at the board and
comes up with a number for how good is
that position
the difference was no human told it how
good the position is
it just learned it and mu zero is the
coolest or scariest of all depending on
your mood
because if the same basic ai system
will learn what the good board position
is regardless of whether it's chess or
go
or shogi or br pacman or lady pac-man or
breakout or space invaders or any number
a bunch of other games
you don't tell anything and it gets this
intuition after a while for what's good
so this is very hopeful for science i
think because if
if it can get intuition what's a good
position there
maybe it can also get intuition for what
are some good directions to go if you're
trying to prove something
if you i often one of the most fun
things in my science career is when i've
been able to prove some theorem about
something and
it's very heavily intuition guided of
course i don't sit and try all random
strings
i have a hunch that you know this
reminds me a little bit about this other
proof i've seen for this thing so maybe
i
first what if i try this nah that didn't
work out but
but this reminds me actually the way
this failed reminds me of that then
so so combining the intuition that
with all these brute force capabilities
uh
i think i think it's going to be able to
help physics too
you